for you to decide you are not here to
speak I've had nothing to do but think
these past few weeks about faithless ones
King to decide mistakes with me or rock we
unite he was a boy and who has a better story
than brand the broken bow that's not so much
[Music]
so what happens to her we both
know what she's about to do
why hasn't bearish left Dragonstone by this point
he sold multiple people that he's betraying Danny
he's sending out tons of letters and this girl
literally told him that the guards are being
suspicious of him first of my name breaking the
chains and mother driving his sentencing today
[Applause]
[Applause] so this is the classic example
of the story requiring Danny to be left by
drogon there were many opportunities for her
to just take off and leave but the execution
of it was off because the writers don't know
how to get to that point naturally [Music]
just don't freeze when you see him I never freeze
I told you a few moments later stay with me please
she's hateful and so am I so I'm a whole lot of
woman what was a whole lot of woman oh I'm sorry
[Music]
I don't know anything else gonna melt a
ram's horn you come with me you die here
yeah Negro that's all you had to say in
winter we must protect ourselves look
after one another I'm defending
our family we're family the four
of us the last of the Starks I'm
not going back north where you go
what' west of Westeros I don't know no one
knows it's where all the map stop that's
where I'm going if not for yourself then for
your child the rain is over but that doesn't
mean your life has to end doesn't mean your
baby has to die [Music] get to this gift No
a few moments later talk to me about your reaction
when you read the script for your final episode
why I was I was really pleased with that so
you're telling me that if you step three feet
to the right he would have survived at the very
least the set decorator could have put more bricks
on the ground come on you can do it hooses mm rest
in peace the only horse in the golden company and
how the hell is this guy still alive what they
see is just the end of the Dothraki essentially
so we had messed up the the most kind of obvious
storytelling possibilities how the hell did your
on some ashore write to the exact spot where
Jamie was coming in and at the exact time I'm
not gonna bother this one I'm gonna go to the
next segment these men are prisoners it is not
over until the Queen's enemies are defeated and
much more defeated do you want them to be there
on their knees they are breathing where's
John he is our prisoner wait wait wait it
was just established like a room doesn't take
prisoners and he would definitely kill John if
you found out that he killed Danny his queen so
a new king has chosen to send you to the Nights
Watch I mean does Jon Snow really have to go
through the Nights Watch braverman the unsullied
are leaving all jokes aside I won't give this
clip the benefit of the doubt because someone
can report the gray weren't late he came back
but yeah hopefully you guys enjoyed the video